hey I'm Emery and I'm love and we're
taking you behind the scenes for a new
music video for like me yeah Marvin and
Murray take EDG exclusively behind the
scenes of their video form only I want
to first establish how you guys met
though you guys both toured with Ed
Sheeran we actually met for the first
time at Wembley Stadium a big deal yeah
no I was sick I walked into his dressing
room and he was so chill and I was like
can you do that again that's alive I
follow him on social media so I knew
that he was great
but he was even better in real life yeah
how does it feel to hear that that's
though no that's all just so sweet I was
gonna say it was horrible the first time
we met no I was just kidding
that was great it was absolutely
wonderful she's quite funny she's quite
uh you got a very goofy charm
[Music]
walk me through the video concept
basically it's just kind of like us
going about our daily lives
but just being lonely you know I mean
just like literally just existing we run
into each other at some point in the
grocery store and have a nice awkward
run-in and then she shuts an elevator on
me but you guys are somewhat connected
right we are yeah I'm do certain things
in my room and then certain things
happen in pair room yeah
supernatural yeah that's me we're going
for we're trying to make a sci-fi music
video so that's here we go I love this I
can't wait for people to see it because
I just think it's so cool and so
different and it's true man like people
are lonely and but there's always
someone there so I feel like that's what
this music videos like I feel like
there's always somebody there but you
don't realize it you know I mean like
you don't realize it somebody's there
and a lot of times like we end up just
being isolated by our own choices you
know I mean wow how big a deal but
really the main the main reason we made
this music video is so that I could show
off my really awkward dance moves we get
a little demonstration absolutely not
lyrically you kind of touched on it but
what was there a moment that inspire
this or a thought that really inspired
this song for me well I started the beat
in an airport on tour
and then I think I was just in
conversation with my friends and and it
was just like oh I'm lonely and then we
were like let's make that into a song
and so we did being on tour all the time
you get pretty lonely so it's very in
the moment situation to be talking about
for us anyway
what do you guys do or who do you call
when you're lonely
is it like your mom loved one anyone I
guess yeah yeah I would say mom hi mom
were you really gonna say mom or did I
put that in your head no I was gonna say
mom I call whoever is has messaged me at
that time I just look at who's there and
just go hello it's that easy
yeah Wow I just I love talking when I
have a problem and I feel lonely I love
speaking it I've got that luxury of
being able to just not be scared to talk
yeah so I love to just call people as
soon as I feel lonely and if you're
wondering how to get love or
anne-marie's attention when they're
feeling lonely well be funny make me
laugh okay show some effort but not too
much effort you can try to I know you
couldn't you can't try too hard because
that just makes me go No
okay which is pretty bad but ya know
that's fair I feel like I like I like
kind of like awkward like nerdiness
quirky and like that kind of a vibe
[Music]
the new track is featured on the 13
reasons why season 3 soundtrack I had
just been a big fan of the show for a
while and it actually been something
that I had wanted to do for a while and
so when they asked me to be part of the
show I was like are you kidding me like
so yeah happened I yeah totally I love
that show so much and I watched it and
totally felt it so it feels so good to
be a part of it
[Music]